-The President and his allies
are now trying out
the Ukraine whistle-blower
as one of Trump's
own appointees admits there was
a quid pro quo.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
You might remember that the
whole Ukraine scandal began
when an anonymous whistle-blower
in the Trump administration
filed a complaint,
alleging that the President
had abused his power
to engage in a criminal act.
-From the whistle-blower
who says, "In the course
of my official duties,
I have received information
from multiple U.S.
government officials
that the President
of the United States
is using the power of his office
to solicit interference
from a foreign country in the
2020 U.S. election."
-This interference includes,
among other things,
pressuring a foreign country
to investigate one
of the president's main domestic
political rivals.
-According to a memo
by the whistle-blower,
a White House official
who listened in
on the call to Ukraine's
president described the call
as crazy, frightening, and
completely lacking in substance
related to national security.
-The official was visibly shaken
by what had transpired,
and in the official's view,
the President
had clearly committed
a criminal act.
-It is not hard for me
to believe that someone
in the Trump administration
witnessed
the President
commit a criminal act.
Trump probably commits crimes
the way people
with Fitbits get in their steps.
"Oh no, I haven't gotten
my crimes in today.
I better go knock over
a liquor store.
I'm so sorry about this.
I'm -- I'm just doing it
to hit my goal."
I mean, if there was
a whistle-blower complaint
for every crime Trump committed,
he'd have to hold another one
of those dumb press conferences
where he's surrounded
by a giant stack of paper.
[ Laughter ]
"And as you can see
from the sign,
these are just the crimes
I've committed today."
So, the whistle-blower is the
one who tipped everyone off
to the fact that something
very corrupt had happened,
but since then, we've seen
the notes from the call.
We've seen text messages
from officials
involved in the scheme.
We've had Trump
and his Chief of Staff
confess on TV, and we've had
one witness after another
come forward, and provide
damning testimony.
We already have
all the evidence.
This is like if during
the O.J. trial they not only
had the gloves,
but dozens of witnesses,
a tape of O.J. confessing
and a note inside the gloves
that said,
"If found at crime scene,
return to O.J. Simpson,
the murderer."
[ Laughter and Applause ]
And yet -- and yet --
Trump and his allies
remain obsessed
with the whistle-blower.
They've tried to paint
the whistle-blower as some sort
of shadowy, anti-Trump operative
who's biased against him.
And Trump has repeatedly called
for the whistle-blower's
identity to be revealed.
-I think that the whistle-blower
gave a lot of false information,
and you have to see who
the whistle-blower is.
Once I release the transcript,
which was almost immediately,
the whistle-blower's report
was very wrong.
So once I released that call,
I released a very detailed
version of that call,
all of a sudden
the whistle-blower's
report was incorrect,
and the whistle-blower
seems to have disappeared.
-No, the whistle-blower
did not disappear.
The only people who can
disappear are David Copperfield
and Steven Miller
if you expose him to garlic.
[ Laughter ]
Be gone, demon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Also, just because
you don't know someone
doesn't mean that person
has disappeared.
The whistle-blower still exists.
They're just anonymous.
Trumps' like a dog who thinks
the tennis ball disappeared
just because you rolled it
behind the couch.
"What the hell? We were just
playing with that ball.
[ Laughter ]
And now, thin air, poof,
gone forever."
We all have the actual
evidence now.
And yet, Trump and his allies
are still obsessed
with the whistle-blower.
On Monday, Trump tweeted
the whistle-blower gave
false information, he must be
brought forward to testify.
Written answers, not acceptable.
So there you go.
Trump wants the Ukraine
whistle-blower outed,
and he says written questions
are not acceptable.
Of course, when Trump had to
answer his own questions
as part of Robert Mueller's
Russia investigation,
he felt a little different
about the acceptability
of written answers,
even claiming that he
personally wrote
the answers himself.
-He hired 18 people.
-Didn't answer questions
on obstruction.
-Well, wait a minute.
I did answer questions.
I answered them in writing.
-Not on obstruction.
-I don't know.
I answered a lot of questions.
They gave me questions.
I answered them in writing.
About what?
Yeah, my lawyers
aren't working on that.
I'm working on that.
I write the answers.
My lawyers don't write answers.
I write answers.
-No, you don't. No.
No one believes you wrote
the answers.
for one thing, if Trump had
actually written the answers,
they'd be full of misspellings.
Trump has misspelled
his wife's name,
his own name,
the word "country,"
and the word "Republicans."
Can you imagine Robert Mueller
trying to sift through
those answers?
What are Ru-Publicans?
Are those fans of RuPaul?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You see,
Republicans stand by Trump.
Whereas, Ru-Publicans think it's
time for him to sashay away.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This obsession -- this obsession
with the whistle-blower's
identity has now gone so far off
the rails that both Trump
and his allies in Congress
like Kentucky Senator Rand Paul
are openly calling
on the media to find out
who the whistle-blower is,
and print their name.
-You know who it is.
You just don't want
to report it.
CNN knows who it is,
but you don't want to report it.
And you know you'd be doing the
public a service if you did.
-The whistle-blower needs
to come before Congress
as a material witness.
I say tonight, to the media,
do your job and print his name.
And I say to my colleagues,
if shifty Schiff will not let
Hunter Biden come,
and if you will not bring
the whistle-blower forward,
every Republican in Congress
should take a walk
and say this is a farce.
-I agree with one part of that.
Republicans should definitely
take a walk.
Because it's always fun
to watch Republicans walk,
just like when Trump wanders
around in circles
on the White House lawn like a
retiree looking for crab grass.
I mean, look at him.
He should be carrying a rake
and a bottle of weed killer.
Also, I love that when he gets
lost and doesn't know
where to go, he just stands
completely still,
hoping people forget
he's there.
He's like an extra
on a movie set who forgot
what he's supposed to do.
I'm pretty sure I saw him
once in the background
of "Goodfellas."
Look at him just standing there
trying to blend in
with the background
like a regular lizard
who thinks he's a chameleon.
[ Laughter ]
"So lucky I turned Green."
Trump and his allies are fixated
on the whistle-blower because
the actual evidence is damning
and they have no response.
That's why their defense
keeps changing.
For example, Trump and his GOP
allies went from insisting
that he did nothing wrong
to arguing that there was
no quid pro quo with Ukraine.
Although,
Trump wasn't always clear
on the exact wording
of the phrase.
-There's no quid pro quo.
No demand. No pressure.
No threat.
-There's no quid pro quo.
There was no quid pro quo.
-There is no quid pro quo.
-There was no quid pro quo.
There was no quid pro quo.
But listen to this,
there is no pro quo.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
There was no pro quo.
So, doesn't that mean
there was a quid?
No pro quo sounds like something
you'd say on a trip to Europe
to explain you don't speak
the language.
"Scusi, no pro quo.
No pro quo, senor."
But that's been the Republican
argument this whole time.
There was no quid pro quo.
Then yesterday, we found out
that one of Trump's
own appointees said
there was a quid pro quo.
And yet, instead of listening
to that evidence,
Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham dismissed
the entire impeachment inquiry
all together.
-I've written
the whole process off.
I think this is a bunch of BS.
-Man, these guys are so
desperate to suck up to Trump,
and keep their tee times
at his golf course.
I mean, look at this photo
of Graham and Paul
golfing with Trump.
Rand Paul looks like
the doctor who delivered
Arnold Schwarzenegger
and Danny DeVito
in the movie "Twins."
[ Laughter ]
Lindsey Graham is making excuses
now because he's getting
what he wants out of Trump,
and doesn't care what
laws Trump breaks.
Today, for example Trump
and Graham got together
at the White House to brag
about how many judges
they'd pushed
through the Senate.
-Lindsey, I'd like to have you
come up and say a few words.
You've been terrific.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
-Well, in theory, at 4 o'clock,
we're going to vote
on two more judges.
So, I'll move
this thing forward.
[ Laughter ]
-"Quick, quick,
I don't have much time.
I'm about to get impeached.
I need to get my crimes in."
Trump and his allies
are desperately trying to out
the whistle-blower because
they have nothing left.
Now, they're just ignoring
all the evidence.
Eventually, Republicans
are going to say, "Sure,
there was a quid
but there was..."
-No quo pro.
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]